[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis herzlich willkommen an
diesem samstagabend zu den nachrichten
und dabei schauen wir natürlich auch
nach münchen und rom christi zum
vorletzten wettkampftag guten abend
unsere großen themen
sorgen gasversorgung russland kündigt
einen weiteren lieferstopp an die
ukraine ist präsident spricht von
erpressung
wege aus der getreide krise in rumänien
kommen erste lieferungen jetzt auch per
zug an um harten blockaden in der
ukraine umgehen zu können und
medaillenregen für deutsche athleten in
münchen holen die deutschen kanuten
gleich zweimal gold in rom spring
cristina und elena wachsen zu bronze
seit russland bekanntgegeben hat ab ende
august für drei tage kein gas mehr nach
deutschland zuliefern wachsen hier die
sorgen das könnte noch knapper werden
die preise noch weiter steigen der
ukrainische präsident wirft russland vor
die weltweiten energiemärkte zu
terrorisieren
ein bericht von pablo sie dabei
russland begründet den lieferstopp
erneut mit wartungsarbeiten erneut soll
es um eine turbine gehen die ankündigung
haben diesmal recht kurzfristig eine
glaubwürdige erklärung ich glaube die
abschaltung bestätigt dass nun noch
einmal dass wir uns auf die russischen
gas nicht verlassen kann es kann immer
wieder passieren dass unter einem
vorwand das gas abgeregelt wird und
deswegen müssen wir uns absichern wir
müssen gas sparen um uns darauf
vorzubereiten zur not eben auch ohne
russisches gas durch den nächsten winter
zu kommen nord stream 1 verläuft von der
russischen ostseeküste über 1200
kilometer bis nach lubmin in mecklenburg
vorpommern schon jetzt vor der wartung
kommt nur etwa 20 prozent der
lieferkapazität an der ukrainische
präsident die lenski spricht von
erpressung
der gasfluss nach deutschland durch nord
stream 1 wird wieder und wieder
reduziert wir hören absurde statements
dass man das über nord stream zwei
kompensieren könnte das einzige was
diese streams wirklich nach europa
liefern sind probleme
energie als druckmittel im krieg das
gilt auch im fall des umkämpften
atomkraftwerks aprilia eine der seltenen
aufnahmen aus dem inneren des kraftwerks
soll russische militärfahrzeuge zeigen
die anlage wurde schon mehrfach
beschossen den frontverlauf ändert das
aber nicht hauptschauplatz der
vergangenen tage die von moskau
annektierte halbinsel krim über der
stadt sewastopol soll heute eine drohne
abgeschossen worden sein laut behörden
trafen trümmerteile das hauptquartier
der schwarzmeerflotte die eliteeinheit
ist strategisch und symbolisch wichtig
für moskau vor wenigen tagen wurde der
kommandeur ausgetauscht russland will
nach den angriffen auf die creme in den
letzten wochen keine schwäche zeigen
angesichts der durch den ukraine krieg
hohen energiepreise und inflation wird
über weitere entlastungen diskutiert die
chefin des deutschen gewerkschaftsbundes
fach chemie fordert dass die maßnahmen
auch in der breite spürbar sein müssten
auch weitere entlastungen für
unternehmen etwa eine absenkung der
stromsteuer bringt die
wirtschaftspolitische sprecherin der
unions-fraktion klöckner
trotz der geplanten senkung der
mehrwertsteuer auf gas wird wohl bei
einigen das geld nicht reichen um die
hohen gasrechnungen noch bezahlen zu
können beim mannheimer energieversorger
mvv gibt es bereits jetzt ein
nothilfefonds der in solchen fällen
einspringen kann und gas sparen wird mit
einem bonus belohnt anfang juni hat sich
angeschaut wie das funktioniert bei
familie grant in mannheim sind die
energiekosten zurzeit das gesprächsthema
durak ans lebt mit sohn stefan und
dessen frau in einem haus aus den 60er
jahren
36.000 kilowattstunden gas verbrauchen
sie im jahr die kosten dafür sind
erschreckend nach dem aktuellen stand
liegen wir etwa bei 100 euro pro monat
und die schätze mal dass es im nächsten
jahr mit den gaspreiserhöhungen
mindestens 150 euro im monat mehr sein
werden beim mannheimer energieversorger
mvv hat sich stefan kranz für den gas
sparbonus angemeldet wenn sie jetzt
weniger gas verbrauchen kann die familie
bis zu 160 euro prämie bekommen
als entlastung und als zeichen der
solidarität sagen aber diese gar
sparaktion macht bewusst nicht nur für
die mvv kunde sondern das könne alle
mannheimer und mannheimerin mitmachen
hohe energiekosten werden wohl manchen
mvv kunden an die finanziellen grenzen
bringen rettung könnte der nothilfefonds
des regionalen energieversorgers sein
wir arbeiten da zusammen mit caritas
diakonie also mit externen stellen die
dann einschätzen wie bedürftig es
sozusagen sind die einzelnen kunden dann
übernehmen wir mit dem nothilfe vorteile
der energierechnung 40.000 euro stehen
erst einmal bereit aus
gesellschaftlicher verantwortung wie es
heißt ähnliche aktionen planen auch
andere energieversorger es hängt auch
davon ab welche ertragskraft die
unternehmen haben aber es macht eben
auch deutlich dass das die jetzige
situation wirklich niemanden kalt lässt
und alles versuchen lösungen zu finden
aber um eines werden verbraucher nicht
herumkommen gas und strom sparen nicht
nur für den eigenen geldbeutel
ja und teuer und knapp auf dem weltmarkt
ist seit kriegsbeginn auch getreide
geschätzte 20 millionen tonnen lagern in
ukrainischen häfen für schiffe konnte
bisher ein bruchteil aus dem land
gebracht werden rund 600.000 tonnen über
den im juli ausgehandelten getreide
korridor durch schwarze meer seit heute
gibt es eine zusatz route und zwar mit
dem zug nach rumänien wolf christian
ullrich berichtet
dies ist der erste zug der getreide aus
der ukraine nach rumänien bringt in den
hafen von balázs 6000 tonnen getreide
werden in den kommenden tagen von hier
aus über die donau zum schwarzmeerhafen
konstanzer und von dort in die welt
verschifft
wir sind hocherfreut an diesem
historischen tag dabei zu sein dies ist
das erste mal nach 15 jahren dass auf
diesen gleisen einzug im angesicht des
krieges öffnen wir eine neue route für
das getreide
seit zwei monaten arbeitet man daran die
letzten vier kilometer gleise mit
ukrainischer spurweite wieder in gang zu
bringen die von der grenze bis in den
rumänischen hafen reichen das ist jetzt
gelungen
wir planen das zunächst 100 weitere
waggons nach graz kommen ukrainische
unternehmer haben jetzt einen neuen weg
nach europa
die neue route ergänzt die bemühungen
der vereinten nationen das dringend
benötigte getreide aus der ukraine in
die welt zu bringen
generalsekretär ich besuchte heute in
istanbul einen der wenigen frachter die
derzeit mit getreide aus der ukraine
unterwegs sind
die primove ich bin sehr bewegt ein
schiff richtung afrika gesehen zu haben
das ist von großer wichtigkeit für die
menschheit
im hafen graz bauen sie jetzt einen
neuen kai um in zukunft noch mehr
getreide aus der ukraine in die welt zu
verschiffen
jan vororten odessa ist für uns herr
hebestreit hannah inwiefern zahlt sich
denn das getreide abkommen für die
ukraine bereits aus
so im globalen kampf gegen den hunger
ist es natürlich gut dass eine der
weltgrößten kornkammern wieder liefern
kann die ukraine geht davon aus dass sie
rund fünf millionen tonnen im monat an
getreide wieder exportieren kann dass es
in etwa das niveau was es vor dem krieg
gab den größten teil etwa drei millionen
tonnen der wirt verschifft hier von den
hafen von odessa etwa 15 millionen
tonnen über die donau häfen das haben
wir eben gerade gesehen und der rest
über straße und eisenbahn
das ist natürlich gut für die ukraine
das bringt geld ins land und weckt
erwartungen dass man so ein abkommen
auch für stahl und metallprodukte
vielleicht vereinbaren kann das ist ja
auch für deutschland wichtig große
export der ukraine gehen auch nach
deutschland allerdings dass es noch
zukunftsmusik dem täglichen alltag da
klemmt es wohl noch wir haben mit
jemandem von der hafenverwaltung
gesprochen der hat uns gesagt immer mal
wieder fehlt ein stempel bei den
kontrollen oder eine unterschrift man
darf einfach nicht vergessen hier gibt
es ein abkommen an dem zwei parteien
beteiligt sind die miteinander im krieg
sind danke für diese einschätzung
hebestreit auch so besser
und jetzt einen blick nach berlin nach
zwei jahren corona pause öffnet die
bundesregierung an diesem wochenende
wieder ihre
besucherinnen und besucher können das
kanzleramt und die verschiedenen
ministerien besichtigen es gibt
führungen und talkrunden mit den
mitgliedern des bundeskabinetts wie zb
hier mit finanzminister lindner für die
aktuelle an der regierung ist es das
erste mal dass die gäste begrüßt
bundeskanzler scholz wird morgen im
kanzleramt dabei sein
es ist ein beispielloser vorgang die
intendantinnen und intendanten der ard
haben der amtierenden spitze des
rundfunks berlin brandenburg rbb das
vertrauen entzogen hde chef bucher
erklärte mit dieser geschäftsleitung
werde die aufarbeitung nicht zügig
gelingen vorher hatte die vorsitzende
des rundfunkrats sie amt niedergelegt
die krise beim rbb dreht sich um
vorwürfe der vetternwirtschaft und
vorteilsnahme gegen die abberufenen
intendanten schlesinger carsten behrendt
berichtet
das vorgehen gegen den rbb von seiten
der aig spitze hat es so noch nie
gegeben der senderverbund entzieht der
kompletten rbb geschäftsleitung um deren
interesse brandstetter das vertrauen
wir die intendantinnen und intendanten
der ard haben kein vertrauen mehr dass
der geschäftsführende leitung des
senders die aufarbeitung der diversen
vorfälle zügig genug gelingt nach wie
vor erfahren wir immer neue vorwürfe
ausschließlich aus der presse es ist das
nächste kapitel in der affäre und die
entlassene intendantin patricia
schlesinger es geht um vetternwirtschaft
und bonuszahlungen für die komplette
führungsebene in der kritik auch die
aufsichtsgremien des senders heute
morgen hat die chefin des rbb rundfunk
graz ihren sofortigen rücktritt erklärt
ihr stellvertreter nimmt gegenüber dem
zdf stellung zum ard vertrauensentzug
findet etwas unglücklich nun mit dieser
formulierung darzustellen vertrauen
entzogen jetzt spekulieren was heißt das
im nachhinein bildungsdirektorin
abgesetzt werden wir müssen ja weiter
sitzung machen das haus brauche eine
führung
findet die alle direktoren sozusagen
ihrer ämter enthoben werden sollten wer
übernimmt die aufgaben die
stellvertreter oder wie auch immer
von der rbb leitung heute keine
offizielle stellungnahme der vorsitzende
des deutschen journalisten verbands
hofft auf einen befreiungsschlag
das ist also jetzt eine neuaufstellung
beim rbb gibt und das ist wichtig nicht
nur für die zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
nicht nur für den rbb die führungsetage
sondern ganz besonders natürlich für
diejenigen sozusagen im maschinenraum
die jeden tag berichten müssen und die
voller wut und scham sind
am montag will sich der rbb
verwaltungsrat erneut mit der affäre
beschäftigen
es ist ein heimtückischer angriff vor
dem man sich nicht schützen kann
vergangene nacht wurden in niedersachsen
zwei gullideckel von einer brücke auf
die a 7 geworfen einer traf die
windschutzscheibe eines vw golf der
fahrer wurde schwer verletzt seine
beifahrerin schwebte zeitweise in
lebensgefahr
der zweite gullydeckel beschädigte in
der gegenrichtung mehrere fahrzeuge eine
mordkommission ermittelt ein
tatverdächtiger wurde bereits
festgenommen
so schlimm wie befürchtet ist es dann
doch nicht gekommen heftige unwetter
haben die menschen zum teil aber
trotzdem in atem gehalten
überflutete und unterspülte straßen gab
es zum beispiel in dortmund hier ist der
hauptbahnhof seit dem morgen lahmgelegt
zu zugausfällen und behinderungen kommt
es auch in teilen baden württembergs und
in bayern bei
oberstdorf direkt am alpenrand brachten
die wassermassen einen hang zum rutschen
der dauerregen hat den pegelstand vieler
flüsse steigen lassen
9 europameisterschaften in einer stadt
münchen feiert die european
championships und die sportlerinnen und
sportler begeistern die menschen die
stimmung wird ausschließlich mit
superlativen beschrieben über eine stadt
im sportfieber christoph giesel
festwetter ist es wahrlich nicht heute
vormittag in der münchner innenstadt der
vorletzte tag der european championships
er beginnt im nieselregen und doch die
feier laune lassen sich die menschen
hier an der strecke der gier nicht
nehmen
es ist fantastisch hier zu sein ein teil
dieser menge zu sein die athleten
anzufeuern
event die ganze stadt lebt eigentlich
jetzt gerade die ganze woche nur für
diese europameisterschaften das größte
multi sport ereignisse in deutschland
seit olympia 72 es hat münchen in seinen
bann gezogen 9 europameisterschaften
gleichzeitig an wettkampfstätten
verteilt über die gesamte stadt volle
ränge diese woche etwa beim
beachvolleyball am königsplatz und eine
stimmung im olympiastadion die
athletinnen und athleten zu
höchstleistungen treibt dann wie das
publikum mit gegangen sind wie lauten
ausgerastet ist und
irgendwie ein heimpublikum
unbeschreiblich doch begeisterung löste
sportevent auch deshalb aus weil es eben
nicht nur um sport geht die championship
sind auch ein großes festival mit
kleinkunst und musik im olympiapark mehr
als eine million menschen haben
wettkämpfe und festival schon besucht
auch ein fingerzeig in richtung einer
neuen deutschen olympia bewerbung eines
ist wichtig wenn wir das tun dann
sollten wir es auch ganz selbstbewusst
machen und sagen münchen hat gezeigt wir
können es aber lasst uns dann bitte auch
mitreden wie es aussehen soll klar ist
schon jetzt dieses mini olympia in
münchen deshalb neue standards gesetzt
für künftige sportliche großereignisse
ja und wie ließ heute sportlich
christine münchen also bisher recht gut
der tag ist ja noch lang aber der
vorletzte wettkampftag begann mit einer
bronzemedaille für die deutsche geherin
saskia feige aus leipzig die 25 jährige
zeigt in einer stunde 29 25 minuten eine
starke leistung mit lange vorne mit und
musste nach 20 kilometern nur der
grieche in trees beauty und der polin gp
den vortritt lassen
weitere drei medaillen gab es für die
deutsche kanu flotte em-gold für
sebastian brendel im einer-canadier auf
der regattastrecke in oberschleißheim
siegte auch der kano vierer dazu bronze
im k2 der frauen
wer mit 34 nach fast 5000 metern in
seinem einer-canadier noch so viel kraft
für einen fulminanten endspurt hat der
wird mehr als verdient europameister für
sebastian brendel der zweite em-titel
hier in münchen der fünfzehnte insgesamt
in seiner langen karriere auch die tokyo
olympiasieger max rendschmidt tom
liebscher und max lemke dürfen sich
zusammen mit dem ronald rauhe nachfolger
im k4 bot jacobs schock über gold freuen
früh gehen sie in führung kontrollieren
das rennen und gewinnen knapp aber doch
souverän vor der slowakei und frankreich
und dann gibt es noch eine
bronzemedaille für den dkv für paulina
paszek und julia hacke im k2 über 500
meter
[Applaus]
beim tischtennis rekordeuropameister
timo boll im viertelfinale ausgeschieden
gegen seinen vereinskollegen d'anjou der
nun zu den deutschen medaillen
hoffnungen zählt
dann zu wird morgen sogar um gold
kämpfen der düsseldorfer sieg im
halbfinale mit 4 zu 1 gegen den früheren
wm-zweiten matthias falk aus schweden
auch nina mittelham erreicht das morgige
endspiel sie bezwingt in ihrem
semifinale in einem deutschen duell
die damit die bronzemedaille geholt wie
auch sabine winter nach der
halbfinalniederlage gegen die
österreicherinnen volker nowak platz
drei wird nicht mehr ausgespielt
und zum fußball aufsteiger werder bremen
dreht am dritten bundesliga-spieltag
spektakulär die partie bei borussia
dortmund und feiert den ersten sieg
durch drei treffer binnen sechs minuten
kurz vor abfiff gewinnt bremen beim bvb
3 2 augsburg mainz 1 2 stuttgart
freiburg 0 zu 1 leverkusen weiter
erfolglos 0 zu 3 gegen hoffenheim
wolfsburg schalke null zu null das
abendspiel union gegen leipzig gestern
gladbach härter 100 morgen frankfurt
köln und die bayern in bochum unter
zugzwang denn ein duo ist vorbeigezogen
gladbach wegen der besseren tordifferenz
vorläufig spitzenreiter vor mainz mit
ebenfalls sieben punkten die bayern
können morgen noch als einziges team den
dritten saisonsieg verbuchen dortmund
rutscht runter auf 6 am tabellenende
bleibt leverkusen nach drei niederlagen
an drei spieltagen definitiv
schlusslicht und ausführlich zum
spieltag alles im aktuellen sportstudio
von 23 uhr an in dem dunja hayali simon
terodde von schalke 04 als gast begrüßt
und bei den schwimm
europameisterschaften in rom gab es die
fünfte medaille für das deutsche team im
wasserspringen die schwestern cristina
und elena wachsen jetzt erst zum zweiten
mal bei einem großereignis zusammen
antraten sicherten sich bronze im
synchronspringen vom zehn meter turm
hinter dem bus aus england und der
ukraine also wirklich heute echt viel
los und uns im sport dankeschön
christine noch kurz zum wetter der
dauerregen im süden hat heute
nachgelassen auf welches wetter sie sich
morgen einstellen können das erfahren
sie gleich von christa haben das heute
journal können sie an diesem abend um
22.45 sehen mit anne gellinek schön an
[Musik]
guten abend die regenmengen die gestern
und heute vor allem im osten und im
süden des landes gefallen sind hier in
der spitze bis 140 liter pro
quadratmeter
verschaffen der natur zwar eine
verschnaufpause
die aktuelle dürre lindern können sie
aber nicht zumal sich jetzt das
azorenhoch wieder zu uns ausbreitet und
alle tiefst samt ihres regens im norden
blockiert heute nacht gibt es im
südosten noch ein paar schauer von
westen her klar dass auf ihr witz dann
kühl mit bis 9 grad an der ostsee bleibt
es mild mit 17 grad morgen früh morgen
vormittag ist es in der westhälfte
zunächst oft sonnig im osten bewölkt mit
einzelnen schauern über dem erzgebirge
den bayrischen wald und den alpen
nachmittags werden die wolken von
nordwesten dichter und haben im
nordseeumfeld auch mal einen schauer
oder ein gewitter im gepäck die
temperaturen dazu sind mit 22 bis 28
grad angenehm bis zur wochenmitte wird
es aber im ganzen land schon wieder
wärmer und über 30 grad heiss verbreitet
der august 2022 ist auf dem weg der
heißeste seit beginn der aufzeichnung zu
werden und dazu ist es bis zur
wochenmitte auch schon wieder so gut wie
trocken ja das war es vom wetter einen
schönen abend